will be live in five seconds
from now
are we live we're live now right
in that case good afternoon everyone and
welcome to this meeting of cabinets
uh please can you do a roll call for
azan
yes lisa um so yourself can you just
confirm you can see in here
i can see and hear the proceedings
thank you councillor pemberton i can see
and hear the proceedings
thank you councillor barker
we'll perhaps come back councillor
cargill i can see and hear proceedings
thank you councillor harvey confirmed
can see in here
thank you councillor jennings i can hear
the proceedings
thank you councillor kettle councillor
kettle i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you councillor harry councillor
parry here
good afternoon everybody i can see and
hear all the proceedings thank you
thank you councillor shenson yeah yes
i'm confirmed i can
hear and see the proceedings thank you
we also have with us councillors
junaid and councillor i'm not sure if
councillor dixon
and uh or donald have joined us yet um
can we go back to councillor barker
okay she was here earlier so um
we'll assume that she's joining i can
see that she's just on our way back in
now
okay shall we move on to disclosures of
interest
sorry apologies for absence
there are there are no apologies being
given and councillor barca has now
returned so can you just confirm you can
see in here for us councillor parker
please i can see in here
we both yeah fine
disclosures of interest
i'll take that as a none minutes
can we confirm and sign the minutes of
the meeting please
sorry councillor harvey's asked if he
could speak on the minutes
counselor harvey thank you chairman
uh page four minute number three five
one
third paragraph fourth line
impact of the kovid 19 pandemic to the
council
i think should be pandemic
on the council
so
accepting councillor harvey's proposed
amendment to the minutes
uh are the minutes acceptable
agreed agreed
and is that sufficient to uh have agreed
the minutes
yep that's fine nobody else has got
anything to note thank you
fine uh one announcement and that is a
be an extraordinary meeting of cabinet
at 12 o'clock on the 18th of january
the reason for this is quite simple as
you
probably are all more than well aware
this year's budget is going to be
particularly fraught
and if one looks at the timing of when
we expect to get notification of
settlement
from central government there would not
be sufficient time to do adequate
preparation of a budget
for the schedule cabinet meeting so if
people could just make a note of that
but of course we will send out the
proper notification
uh in due course
did you say the 12 18
sorry 18th
18th to 12 noon i think it worked 18th
at 12 noon
high noon eastern
right so moving on item four
on the agenda treasury management
strategy mid-year review
2020 2021 councillor harvey
thank you leader this paper is presented
because it forms part of the monitoring
process for which members are
responsible
fulfills a requirement under the cypher
code of practice
on treasury management the seven areas
addressed by this report are set out in
paragraph
1.2.2 on page 10
of the papers the bulk of the paper
addresses the economic environment
during the review period which has been
overshadowed by the disruptive
global economic impact of the kovid 19
pandemic
the implications for the council is that
for the foreseeable future
it will be operating against the
background of a depressed
domestic economy that has suffered its
worst
decline in economic activity in the
short term
for 300 years the outcome
of the current negotiations concerning
the uk's future trading relationship
with the eu remain in the balance
although the uk's trading levels with
the eu have declined
in recent years the eu remains the uk's
principal trading partner which
accounted last year
for 43 percent of the uk's exports
and from which the uk sourced 52
of its imports whatever the outcome of
the current negotiations
any degree of disruption arising will
only add
to the difficulties created by the covet
19
pandemic paragraph 2
sets out the recent movements in
interest rates in general
and the decisions taken by the treasury
in particular
to halt the practice some local
authorities have indulged in
to finance the acquisition of commercial
property
something which this council has never
done through loans from the public works
loan board
given the impact of the pandemic there
is every likelihood that the uk
monetary policy will continue to be
conducted for the foreseeable future
in an environment of ultra low interest
rates
paragraph three confirms that there have
been no policy changes
since the council last approved the
treasury management
strategy statement on the 10th of
february this year
nor have there been any changes to the
capital expenditure plans
also approved on that date as stated in
paragraph
four paragraph five of the paper
indicates that the council's fund
manager
has generated a net return of fees
of eight six percent set against the
benchmark
of 0.06 during the first half of the
year
turn the gross investment return
generated during the first half of the
year
was 000 pounds set against a budget
figure
of only 114 000 pounds
section 7 restates that the council has
no external borrowing
and that currently the only intention
for external borrowing
is in connection with the material
recycling facility
the broad messages from this information
in this report therefore are
one interest rates have been
and are likely to remain at historically
low levels
for the next couple of years two
financial markets
are influenced by amongst other factors
economic changes for example the effect
on world trade arising from the trade
conflicts
initiated by the outgoing american
government
and the impact of covet 19 pandemic
which has
caused volatility in asset prices and
hence yields
and three in the context of financial
markets where there is such
uncertainty the council's cautious
approach
to where and how its funds are held
is well merited i ask therefore that
this review
this report reviewing the treasury
management of the council's funds
over the first half of the current
financial year be received
thank you mr chairman thank you
councillor harvey
i will just make two comments one is the
masterly understatement in paragraph 213
the mpc monetary policy committee
acknowledged however that the quote
medium-term projections were a less
informative guide than usual
this is quite a remarkable statement in
the current circumstances
the other uh observation i would just
make
is that in 2223
uh the percentage of debt
to gdp is a hundred and ten percent
which i think is um remarkably high
and may well put a constraint on an
awful lot of borrowing going further
with that does anyone else wish to
make a comment or observation
i'll take that as a no so this is a
recommendation to council
contained on page nine leadership
if she could ask a question yes sorry
there's
no no hand coming up on my thing council
junior
yes i'm not sure whether it's the
appropriate place but i just wondered
whether um
you've got any information updated
information
on the additional restrictions grant um
you know for parts
part tier three business support
uh david buckland did tell me that it
was a december the 11th
businesses would be able to get that
information and i've had
two inquiries but i've also been told
since i spoke to david this morning
that warwick district council and that
announced and launched their
uh additional restrictions grant fund
for
tier three business uh impact on friday
fourth of december
whereas we appear to be waiting until
december the 11th
i wonder if you could update me uh
i'm not sure it actually fits under this
agenda item
counselor junior but nevertheless i'll
allow it
and mr brooklyn can you respond please
i'm just going to pass the buck slightly
from my um chairman to david platts
who's been a bit of a stronger
position to respond on this particular
item thank you mr platts
yes hello good afternoon leader thank
you yeah um just just to respond then so
um the tier three grants at warwick are
actually being dealt with by the
economic development team they're not
using an online
so they're not using the software that
is being provided to warwick
in terms and ourselves in terms of the
actual tier 3 grants that are closed
they're really using it as an extension
to their discretionary grants
so um both warwick and ourselves and all
the other uk civica sites will be
receiving the software on the 11th as
previously stated by david so
it's just that um i think that the the
economic development team
are providing some advice online for um
businesses over there but it's very
similar to the the form that is already
there for our discretionary grant um on
our website as well so it's all very
very similar but the software arrives
for everybody on the 11th of december
as i understand it the businesses in
warwick are definitely getting money
from december the 4th
i don't think we are in a position to
comment on that
councillor junior that's a matter for
warwick district council
so without further ado recommendation to
council on page nine
uh is anyone on cabinet opposed to that
recommendation if so please show
in that case i will take the
recommendation to council on page nine
as unanimously approved so moving on
a biodiversity emergency council of
pemberton
thank you lina members of canada
will be aware that um at the council
meeting on the 19th of october
councillors
junaid and pertiguella uh brought
forward a motion for a declaration of a
biodiversity emergency i don't propose
to
run through the details of that that's
clearly in your papers
officers have considered that in
conjunction with myself as the place
portfolio holder and uh
uh joe bogdan gunnelly is available if
there are any technical questions
um but cutting to uh to the chase really
the recommendation
um is that based on the fact that we
have already declared
a climate emergency that we have a
number of existing plans and programs
in train and will continue so to do
that we do not declare a separate
biodiversity emergency
um just give some reassurance and some
confirmation
i'm a relatively straightforward simple
kind of a guy and uh
for me if you declare a climate
emergency you're going to save the
planet then you've got to save
biodiversity as part and parcel of that
but on a less flippant note with the
climate plan the full expectation is
that biodiversity is actually
part and parcel of what they're what
they're looking at um
and therefore that the any anything
around work around biodiversity action
plans
lobbying awareness raising and funding
will be picked up by the work of the
climate change panel
it is certainly our belief that this is
important
and members are drawn to pages
22 and 23 of the report
and 24 of the report outlining work
that's already already been
under train so on that basis members the
recommendation to cancel
is uh the recommendation that we should
be making to cancel because it will be a
council uh that hears this is that the
council continues with its existing
plans and programs revising to
biodiversity across the district
including through the actions endorsed
following the climate emergency
declaration
and that a biodiversity emergency is not
declared
thank you if anyone wishes to speak can
they please use the hands up function
leader lay down we don't have the hands
up function on the
you need to left if you could if you
need to speak could you please indicate
using the chat function thank you
right i'll go into chat
right in that case uh
councillor cargill then councillor peter
gellar
i think i think i indicated first
actually
i i just i mine was in first
said but one thing i'd just like to
raise or pick up please on 1.3.2
last paragraph it says in order to land
across the district to identify
a suitable site or site to facilitate
projects to promote biodiversity
tree planting educational opportunities
and community allotments
uh i've already had a number well any
number of
my uh residents who have land
uh that were are keen to actually
promote tree planting etc uh which would
fit in neatly with this one
and i would ask two questions one is how
are we going to go
about this are we going to have a call
for sites and
also are there any funding opportunities
to help promote these sites as well
thank you
i i'd probably be saying that uh that
sits squarely with the
climate panel too to come up with the
best policy to inform
how we move forward on that but clearly
on a practical level if uh if somebody's
got land to bring forward then
if there is an immediate opportunity
let's find a way of
taking that forward and perhaps
councillor cargill you could pick that
up with
uh with joe offline but i would
certainly ask if the
the climate panel could pick up um how
how we
uh how we establish a process for that
that seems
squarely within within their remit for
that
thank you councillor junard
yes the the only real protection for
local wildlife sites in particular uh
one aspect of biodiversity
is through the planning system uh and
yet even under the current
um protocols on the current rules
16 of the uh
wildlife sites in south warwick in the
stratford constituency that is not
actually in the whole of stratfor
stratfor district were damaged or
destroyed between 2013
and 2018 and that's with current
protections
only 16 percent of the holder street is
actually covered by wildlife habitat
now what my concern is not about the
good work that is being done by our own
staff
which are i our example what the work
that has been done by joe and others
i understand is because there is a
a new white policy white paper that's
going on at the moment
on planning reforms which has caused a
lot of concerns
amongst wildlife site specialists wild
wildlife specialists but also amongst
councillors up and down the country of
all political flavors
and i have to stretch stress that it is
of all political flavors
the it is the biggest house building
that will take place in 70 years
which if not planned for could cause
huge damage to wildlife and wildlife
places
now what the wildlife trusts and a
variety of other wildlife
organizations and charities are saying
is that the there is within that
84 pages of the uh planning white paper
there is absolutely no mention
at all of climate change or of
biodiversity
and indeed there is a particular
parts of it that say that there will be
a new consultation that will change the
approach
to environmental assessment and
mitigation in the planning system
and that there is the intention to
abolish environmental assessment of
local plans
in favor of a streamlined process for
assessing
environmental impacts and i am reading
verbatim
the white paper provides no guarantee
that the simplified assessment will
offer the same level of environmental
protection
nor does it clarify whether the
environmental impact assessment will be
used in more detailed
development applications so there is
this is a this is universal right across
the environmental uh
world and that they are worried about
the what is in that planning white paper
we need to see that housing developments
are designed with environmental
sensitivity
and with green infrastructure at the
heart climate change yes we
we want to raise that and there has been
something said by government about
climate change
but it is the greatest long-term threat
to biodiversity
and are coupled with the policy
proposals
that are loosening the control
of um environmentalist impact
assessments
um in the white paper
they are really worrying me but also a
lot of other people
so one of the reasons why i want this
biodiversity um
you know the declaration is not to be
just because i want it in the
um in the uh climate change but i want
to be able to make sure
that we're making it clear to government
that this
must not be part of the planning white
paper it is absolutely essential
you know it is not this is not a
political point this is
my degree and my phd are in biodiversity
it's something i know an awful lot about
and i would like to make sure that we
are definitely
um protecting it the the other thing is
i have here the state of nature
report that again is a document that is
print uh printed
and researched nationally that makes it
very worrying um it's very worrying the
content of that that was brought out at
the end of 2019
we do simply must do more than we are
doing now
even with the current protections
wildlife sites
are being destroyed within this district
and we must do more
thank you thank you councillor junior
uh i believe an awful lot of people have
raised
issues with the white paper and i
believe it will probably be revised
councillor peter gallo yes
thank you first of all thank you for
allowing me to speak on this item today
um so the report states the report was
prepared for cabinet states that
there are relevant national planning and
other policies in place
and that the council is already taking
action and that is committed to
undertaking a wide range of biodiversity
measure
as part of the climate change program
and the biodiversity is important to
strafford
on even so i would like to ask was this
responsibility council at both
operational and
strategic level and also in relation to
paragraph 132 of the report where he
stated that there are measures in place
as part of the climate change program of
work
the examples given are excellent but
they are not sufficient
to enhance biodiversity and also i want
to highlight some of the language of the
report
paragraph 139 states that development
proposals are
expected to secure a biodiversity net
gain
but surely it should be that this shall
be required
to secure a net gain the sentence
unless exceptional circumstances apply
worries me a lot
who defines and who adjudicates
these exceptional circumstances
and paragraph 13 1.3
11 states that the funds generated from
biodiversity of setting
have the potential to improve the
biodiversity value of existing green
spaces and again you should read that
these funds
will be used for this aim
regarding the reference to national
planning policies yes
in 2011 the coalition government
published biodiversity 2020
which was a strategy for biodiversity
recovery and enhancement to 20
20 which also actively promoted the move
from offsetting
to biodiversity net gain and i quote
by supporting healthy well-functioning
ecosystems and coherent ecological
networks
however we know now that this has not
been
sufficient or enough to protect our
wildlife because the uk biodiversity
indicators
2020 report which was published in
october
shows the deterioration of uk habitats
and a declining priority species
and he also shows that unfortunately
public sectors investment in
biodiversity conservation has fallen 33
percent
in the last five years and also the 2019
state of nature report which counselor
jun had just
referenced found the numbers of the uk
most important wildlife had fallen by
60 percent in 50 years
um so and obviously i can forward these
reports
uh to to the portfolio holder
if needed so actually we are not doing
enough for our ecosystems and wildlife
and we are being complacent at national
and local
governance levels and also the
there is obviously the um a paragraph
about the designation of local green
spaces which is in the
um mppf but these has to be in the next
core strategy because we've seen
with uh maple maple or green and
neonvale woodland
that actually this is not working well
and these
open green spaces are then um
you know you know they can be actually
proposed for for build development so
um i hope that you all agree that we
must safeguard
our wildlife habitats and enhance and
restore nature in our district
thank you togela uh councillor pemberton
was there anything uh in what councillor
pertiguella said
that you wish to respond to i haven't
heard a single thing that tells me we
should declare a separate biodiversity
emergency
um counselor pertiguella this is a this
is a report to cabinet
uh the wording is as a report to cabinet
this is not
these are not the wordings of policy so
what we're actually about is actually
cracking on and doing some stuff with
this
not uh worrying about whether a cabinet
report says
should would or could it's the policy
that counts and
as far as i'm concerned our officers are
driving towards future policy
we've given the commitments around the
climate change we've given the
commitments around
the the warwickshire plan um we're
looking forward about how we can improve
things um
i've heard nothing that changes uh
the rationale for this recommendation at
all for me thank you
thank you councillor pemberton
councillor parry and then councillor
kettle
thank you leader and i'd just like to
say i'm in support of the proposed
recommendation
principally whilst i i think it's
laudable to have a biodiversity focus
it is part of our climate change
emergency and our focus at the moment
should be on recovery from covid19 the
distribution of the vaccine
and be mindful of the bandwidth of our
officers
who have to be focused on the priorities
that our residents
are really keen to have and the last
thing we want to do is to have any
duplication of any effort
by incorporating this as a separate
agenda
so i'm fully in support that this should
be
as part of our climate agenda in order
to give
officers the right bandwidth and time to
focus on
the real serious things that are
affecting uh the council
this coming year and actually next year
so i'm fully in support of the
recommendation leader thank you
thank you councillor parry and your
point on bandwidth is
extremely well made and extremely
important
councillor kettle i mean following on
from councillor paris point
um i i would add
the fact that we're not putting this
forward for um
or all the proposals put forward as
council members described doesn't mean
that
anybody's not concerned about
biodiversity uh and i listened to
councillor julian carefully earlier on
because i do respect what she says
um but what she has not mentioned is the
very significant
changes the government announced or
order has announced in terms of
policies to support biodiversity um in
the agricultural sector
uh which are massive and are very much
focused
about exactly what um the proposal is
talking about
so i think we in in terms of a national
policy
the government is clearly pushing
forward that agenda
and it is going to be i speak as you
know as a farmer uh
some of those aspirations are going to
be quite a challenge
um but but the focus is to ensure that
we improve across the uk the by the
biodiversity um that we see particularly
in the more
um commercial agricultural areas of the
uk
so i think we can be comfortable
that the government is already doing
that um
and going back to bandwidth it isn't our
job to set
national policy they're already doing it
if there are planning issues as
councillor jefferson's already said
they may be subject to revision but i
don't think this should be used as a
weapon
to try and change planning policy uh
that may be part of a separate
discussion at some point in the future
thank you councillor kettle i see no
more indications that people wish to
speak
so and can i just check do i need
a proposal and a second
or can i simply ask if cabinet members
are opposed to it
yes it's a recommendation to cancel um
so if you could perhaps ask it does
anyone else in the cabinet that have an
objection to it
does anyone in the cabinet have an
objection to
the proposal outlined on page 21 which
is a recommendation
to counsel
i will take that as a no
in that case moving on item seven
long itchington basket and basket heath
neighborhood development plan
pre-submission consultation response
council pemberton
chairman we need sorry
first go on
sorry check maybe you you've skipped
over item six
oh sorry my apologies councillor
pemberton
thank you i haven't realized how many
papers you had on this meeting
six then again uh councillor pemberton
consultation on the draft gypsy and
traveler and travelling show people
supplementary planning document thank
you leader so the
uh this document this spd has
been prepared as an interim measure uh
with the purpose of providing additional
policy guidance within the context of
our existing core strategy
um it takes us some way forward it
doesn't take us where
all the way forward um but members uh
just to give reassurance there is
significant work underway
looking at other options for finding
sites to come forward
um for fresh uh gypsy and traveller
sites
but it is important to give guidance uh
publicly around what is acceptable what
the broad areas of search are
and it is important for us to get this
out into
a public consultation
uh at the earliest opportunity um with
that i can see a number of questions
coming in or comments i'll leave it at
that for the moment
okay thank you i've got cancer o'donnell
thank you leader um it was just raising
a point raised by
um a couple of members of the committee
was
that they felt the allocation the sites
were possibly not fully extensive
and they were concerned that the north
of the district seemed to be
blocked out and that it was very
centralized
and any families where new generations
were hoping to live close to their
families
they wouldn't be able to access sites
close by it was just to be noted that
the
allocation across the district didn't
seem to be um
equal but i understand there are many uh
challenges in the way in accessing
relevant and suitable sites i i think uh
councillor donald makes a a valid point
however
there are significant constraints in
different parts of the district
uh we are not going to find a perfect
solution i mean clearly we want to do
the best that we can
i think that the new south warwickshire
plan does afford opportunities for us to
completely review and look at how we do
this um
so i take all that on board but um
absolutely we need to get this
consultation out to move
further forward thank you uh councillor
cargill and then councillor junior
councillor cargill thank you leader
yeah um with my other hat on i have
as you probably know a number of chips
and trouble sites in my patch
and i will be holding a meeting with
scott tompkinson from county on this
particular subject because
obviously we need to work closely with
county on this particular point
and i will be reporting or i will be
sort of liaising with the council
pemberton on this one because
it's something that we're always all
aware of we need more sites to come
forward
and council donald you know said uh yes
there's not enough sites well there
aren't we know that we really
desperately need more
and uh well we'll have to see how it
goes but we are working on that
i look forward to uh hearing news of
your success councillor cargill
thank you councillor cargill councillor
junaid yes
i was also going to ask about liaison
with the county council because
we are where we are because um that fell
through the liaison with the county
council over
um suitable sites more than a year ago
and i just wondered what kind of uh what
the state of uh discussion was
at the county council uh whether there
was any discussion at
all you can lead a horse to water you
can't make it drink
counselor cargill i see your hand up
comment on that one um there has been a
bit of a
confusion between the two organizations
the two authorities
i i don't know why i do these things but
i've decided that yes i will
i will try and work out with those
common ground between us
so leave that one with me please i will
be reporting back to you i've only just
started this process
uh the meeting i think is next week so i
will come
talk to councillor pemberton on on this
at the first
and earnest opportunity i look forward
to hearing news of your success council
of
cargill councillor shenton
very quick one thank you lead a very
quick one i think this is a good paper i
think we should just move it forward now
as a recommendation i fully support
what's in this paper
um as as council pemberton said
it's it's not it's never going to be
perfect it's
but it is a good paper nevertheless so
i would say can we move forward now
thank you
in that case members of cabinet the
recommendation on page 27
that the draft gypsy and traveler and
travelling show people supplementary
planning document be endorsed for six
week period of
public consultation does any member of
cabinet
object to that recommendation
no thank you members of cabinet then
that is approved
moving on now to the long itchington
basket and basket heath
neighborhood development plan
pre-submission consultation responses
council of pemberton again thank you
leader so the longitudinal basket of
basket heath neighborhood development
plan has now reached
uh the regulation pre-submission stage
um members of cabanas are being asked to
approve the schedule of significant
comments that they'd be endorsed and
submitted
to longitudinal parish council as the
formal response to the pre-consultation
process associated with the draft
longitude and basket and basket heath
neighborhood development plan
which is an appendix too i would say
um this has been moving along on the
basis of some really good work
by the neighborhood development plan
group um across at long itchington
uh covering basket and basket heath i
commend them on their work i also
commend officers on their work
this is a significant move forward in
the process and i
hope that members of cabinet can agree
the recommendation to move to the
to this next stage thank you
thank you councillor pemberton i have to
say
i read through the report in detail
and i was impressed with the comments so
well done officers
uh i see no one wishing to comment
so therefore the recommendation on page
55
that the schedule of significant
comments of dependents won't be endorsed
submitted to the long itchington parish
council as a former response to the
pre-submission
consultation process associated with
draft
long itchington basket and basket heath
neighborhood development plan provided
appendix
ii does anyone in cabinet
object to that recommendation which is
not easy to say
i'll take that as everyone is in
agreement so that recommendation is
approved
so now moving on to item eight
on the agenda the council planner
monitoring mid-year
2020 21 performance report
at councillor cargill thank you very
much indeed
the very first thing i'd like to say is
thanks to the officers for
all the hard work on what has been an
incredibly difficult period
to report on i think we've all seen
the report and what we haven't achieved
but that's not surprising given the
circumstances that we are
at the moment um it's going to be a
little while before we come out of this
and are able to start achieving some of
the goals
and even starting some of them because
we can't report on some of the items at
the moment
um i consider this to be more of an
interim measure
a step simply because we have we've got
to recover ourselves
our situation and start reporting and
that will not be until the new year
um i can't say any more than that leader
i'm afraid that's basically where we are
with this one
thank you councillor cargill and i would
just remind members of cabinet
and other councillors that this is a
summary of the performance during
april to september when there was
maximum disruption from kovid19
councillor junaid
yes um just wondered whether i could ask
a question
about um the item cp2e which is about
broadband
because i understand that there was a
reduction in the amount
um i declared by rishi sunak the
chancellor in his spending review to be
spent
on broadband uh is this likely to impact
on this
uh on on the rollout of broadband
in this district well i'm i'm going to
ask
uh david platts on that particular point
but
we are working very hard with
bduk and also uh we've had our first
meeting with
respondents 5g now 5g may be
mobile technology but it requires fiber
as well
and we are looking at that at the moment
on that specific point
perhaps mr perhaps would like to comment
mr platts yes thank you yeah um
yes there was an announcement of reduced
funding but the community fibre
broadband program is not affected by
that reduction i think it's elsewhere
within the programme so
there's nothing no reduction in the
funding that we are trying to allocate
thank you mr platts uh i see
no other people wishing to ask you a
question
so in that case moving on to the
recommendations on page 71
to know performance uh achieved in year
one of the council plan
to no performance against key service
indicators
and approve changes to targets is set
out below
members of cabinet does anyone
object to those recommendations on page
71
i'll take this as a resounding no in
that case
moving on part c issues arising from
overview and scrutiny committee
none part d cabinet committees
none part e on block items and these are
only for noting so that's
item 9 housing investment panel item 10
climate change and then urgent business
item 11 there is none so i therefore
declare
the meeting closed thank you everyone
thank you very much